the question of romanticizing a
religious tradition in its assuming that
it has an ecological perspective which
is helpful is a very good caveat I don't
think in that sense we need to eliminate
or erase any tradition from
participating whether it's a particular
Buddhist group or a particular say
evangelical Christian group who we
assign a perspective to what's more
important i think is to ask what are
they doing what is the particular group
doing for example the Dalai Lama is an
outspoken spiritual leader in this
regard what's happening on the ground in
the Tibetan refugee communities in India
what type of five-year plans do they
have what kind of environmental concerns
do they have these are you know
interesting research questions so it's
this is an wide open field so when I
talk about it as an academic field once
you begin to dig below the surface and
enter into all of the differentiation
that's there it's it's very rich and so
2g in Taiwan is a very good example of a
tradition which on the surface in terms
of its Buddhist it's an overtly Chan or
Zen or meditational oriented tradition
its organizational dynamics cause a
question some people are very concerned
about how to G organizes itself and
recruits new members that I think is a
very fair question I've visited their
recycling centers I have seen three
football field-sized area organized on
one side into it's like a bizarre it's
the most interesting thing you walk down
areas the size of this room where they
have sewing machines that are being
refurbished they've been thrown away and
people are working on Reaper you go to
the next one's lawnmowers I mean it's
like this it's amazing fellini kind of
movie walking down this
there's said because it's you know dirty
and they try and clean it up but it's
recycling stuff on the other side so all
these elders and they are working with a
roll of material it's obviously come
from a factory I mean it's at its 12
feet inside in the height and it's a 75
feet long this material and they're
cutting it and they're making sweaters
vests hats shirts and this is all for
disaster relief but all of this cloth is
recycled plastic bottles and you see
outside the high school students from
the local high school who have come
after school and they're sorting all of
the plastic that's coming into the wyatt
green all the colors this outfit sends
them to be fragmented pelletized in
their own plant because they haven't
found here's an entrepreneurial activity
waiting to happen they then recombine it
and spin it and they do have a factory
that already does that they spin it into
cloth this cloth that they are sending
out to disaster relief for example at
the New Orleans hurricane to G was there
and they were handing out this material
so there's some very good questions with
regard both to the ideologically framing
of a tradition that it has a mano-a-mano
logical and it's obviously it doesn't
doesn't dig deep enough maybe I could
point out the way the way that you
conducted your books on each religious
tradition has a whole variety of
scholars who are weighing in on that so
yeah I think part of what you do you
have like a polyphonic approach to these
traditions so that it's not you haven't
presented the Buddhist take on the
college exam is right it's because the
way your volumes are set up it's already
a different city perspectives yeah and
in addition to that there was a turn
that we made during the conference's
from the very beginning namely not
simply religious scholars
even that I I didn't mention initially
we chose to work with scholars and very
few religious leaders there were some
who are invited who showed already a
concern for environmental activity many
scholars who came had no overt interest
in environmental issues with regard to
their studies and religion but we could
see it or others could see it because we
had experts in these fields advising us
and they would say you know there's this
person who's been working on the Diamond
Sutra and she keeps talking about
environmental issues kind of in the
background she could've invite her and
see if she wants to bring it forward so
within a tradition of plurality of
voices and then religious leaders and
then to turn towards scientists
environmental activists policy people
who are musical to religion so an
Islamic policy person who was aware of
environmental issues in his or her
country those were all so we wouldn
target some of those people to bring
them along to they were incredibly
helpful because they have on the ground
resources